le textile est l'une des industries les
plus polluantes au monde ces dernières
années loeb cycling qui permet de
redonner vie à des matières oublier
s'est développé à rambouillet les
enchanteuses fabrique des accessoires à
partir d'objets et tissus déjà utilisé
on s'est lancé toutes les deux dans le
développement des accessoires à leurs
accessoires haut de gamme pour tout ce
qui est sac à main et c est aussi dans
tout le côté sac havre ac emballe tout
voilà pour trouver une alternative
papier plastique et elle travaille
uniquement en local en nouant des
relations avec des entreprises du
territoire et certaines sont
surprenantes
le dernier partenariat avec le
concessionnaire citroën à rambouillet
qui nous donne donc ces bâches qu'on
revalorise en accessoires de mode et on
a fait dernièrement une expo chez eux
avec les accessoires réalise avec fort
matière qui a très bien fonctionné
prochain objectif utiliser les anciens
rideau du cinéma vox de rambouillet pour
en faire des accessoires
les créations seront présentées lors de
deux défilés on a vraiment envie de
développer des choses qui soient sur
l'univers du cinéma et faire plein de
choses inattendues ce jour là comme
passer un film sur effectivement
peut-être le cinéma avoir des des sacs
qui soit vraiment lié au monde du cinéma
par exemple un sac en forme de bobines
et des sacs aussi avec des affiches de
cinéma qui pourrait être brodé sur le
velours rouge du cinéma
le premier défilé privé aura lieu le 17
septembre et le seconde public le 26
septembre